je ne vous apprendrai rien n'est fait
tellement froid cet hiver que presque
toute la surface des cinq grands lacs
est gelé on parle d'environ 90% de la
surface mais contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait croire ça peut avoir un impact
positif plus tard sur l'industrie
maritime
reportage mathieu dion du jamais vu
depuis une vingtaine d'années aux dires
des experts les grands lacs sont gelés à
90%
on en a beaucoup entendu parler le
fameux vortex polaire où le tourbillon
polaire il s'agit en fait d'une masse
d'air arctique qu'on retrouve plus près
du pôle qui se déplaçait plus
fréquemment que d'habitude sur les
grands lacs et la glace ont soudainement
accessibles ces grottes qu'elle façonne
le temps d'un hiver sur le lac supérieur
les images sont spectaculaires mais les
eaux gelées retarderont les déplacements
par bateau si on prend l'ensemble de la
saison comme tel on va voir des
augmentations minard de coûts de
transport l'industrie devait reprendre
du service le 21 mars pour pouvoir
emprunter la voie maritime du fleuve
saint-laurent de saint-lambert jusqu'aux
grands lacs
elle devra attendre une semaine de plus
en raison des glaces et les voyages
prendre de deux à trois fois plus de
temps dans les premiers jours ça
habituellement favorable pour les eaux
du parlement le port de montréal estime
qu'il n'y a pas lieu d'appeler à l'aide
que les effets seront somme toute
bénéfique car les niveaux d'eau du
fleuve pourront demeurer élevé
la belle couche de glace que sur les
grands lacs empêche l'eau de s'évaporer
haute ou basse température
alors on garde en fait un bon réservoir
d'eau ce qui fait que la capacité
portante des navires marchands vont être
plus grandes que celles qu'on a connues
dans les dernières années
mais l'hiver peut encore faire des
siennes et le record de 1979 ou les lacs
été gelé à 95% pourrait être fracassé
pour certains cela soit encore assez
froid donc probablement qu'on pourrait
peut-être battre des records
alors d'ici le printemps il n'y a qu'à
espérer que le froid persiste ou laisse
place à la chaleur tout dépend de quel
point de vue on se place ici ma tu dis
on radio canada montréal